quand et squillaci va pas et tout ça en
toi c'est trop gros ça va trop vite
surtout et c'est aux connards regarde
les sont tout le temps par si ça va nous
retomber dessus c'est mes amis c'est des
bons gars je te jure douce et tes amis
c'est des potes de poker tu les connais
que de la nuit ils en ont rien à [ __ ]
de ta gueule tout ce qui les intéresse
et flamber baiser l'écu s'en fout plein
pif va droit dans le mur avec eux je
sais au fond de toi tu le sais tout en
tentant d'y dolly on va refourguer cache
encore de trois mois on va faire
prospérer après les quito c'est du vent
et on y sera dur derrière nous puis sont
venus sur baiser serait déjà fait corps
allait passer avec tu vas d'offrir une
piste derrière les barreaux
à demain
tu peux pas compter
je te fais confiance à mon équipe
vous allez vous comme ça je n'ai pas dit
de partir quand même bien est-ce que
j'ai une tronche à prendre que des
pouliches vous prenez pour qui là pour
un pompiste
du coup tu prends pas pour un combat
tout parent est au courant pour autre
affaire il paraît que vous avez pris
plus de 5 100 briques toi tu te pointes
avec 10 plaqués tu crois qu on est
quittes
tu as la moitié de ce que tu as pris
tu m'as donné 5 je devais 36 vous l'avez
pas parler d'autre chose je veux 250
bars et pendant trois mois je vais dans
trois jours
ok mais si tu arrives pas
les affaires se traitent par la prudence
par l'autorité et les bons avis tu
aurais dû relire cicéron avant de te
lancer dans des opérations financières
dont tu n'as pas mesuré les conséquences
désastreuses un beau patrons de pme
c'est un patron capable d'engager tout
son avoir financier dans son entreprise
c'est celui qui exerce des fonctions
réelles et unique de responsabilité et
de gestion celui qui met en jeu son
savoir et en cas d'échec son honneur je
ne suis pas certain que tu puisses te
vanter de réunir toutes ces qualités à à
tamaris à vin capable d'impulser tu
compte en sortir comment déjà en vous
demandant d'arrêter m'insulter dur ma
femme et l'office ta femme est avant
tout ma fille et mon fils mon petit fils
l'idée de les imaginer un jour dans une
situation précaire
par ta faute motorisée de parler comme
je longtemps que cela te plaise ou non
garçon garçon bien avoir bien vu ça va
si tu fais dire tu veux tu as ton tu te
regardes ton assiette
regarde là et à 10000 extrême dix mille
de plus si tu marchais reversed peu plus
avec la bêta laisse pas pourquoi tu peux
pas accepter ça va revient pas je te dis
je te donne dix mille euros de plus si
tu va servir cette perry qui arrête les
conneries
eric tire toi si tu la payes tu veux que
je fasse cet art du bijou emballé coup
je le fais je vais écouter rue paquet
range a réussi je te lui manque patients
pour jacques est amer qu'est ce qu'il ya
vous croyez vous êtes tout permis parce
que vous avez dû plaît c'est sam yeh
gardez vous un peu avec vous trouverez
toute une pièce la tâche
pour tout à fait faux bond fsq félix et
ses soutiens
opelmouton patron je les achète tout de
suite sa maladie cholet pour moi qui
tiens voilà je leur achète pour
l'établissement fils de [ __ ] chien comme
quoi tout bouge toi tu fais la queue